first i have to ask you about principal
photography on
justice league proper because i don't i
don't really know your your schedule and
how everything kind of fell
out with that so you were kind of
touching on this earlier
as an actor you only have so much
control over everything so where was
your mind at when you found out that
zach wasn't going to get to finish the
film had you already shot your stuff is
is it were you shooting later on in the
production process what what exactly
happened there
i already shot my stuff and um
then i hear the tragic and
almost inconceivably awful news um
and as a mother as a parent
um it was
that was just like oh my god my heart
just went out to him into
deborah and i just felt like
that's just something that you know and
any one of us would have such a hard
time to recover from
you know from something like that it
felt
so sad for him i know how family
oriented they are they have the kids
around them to come on set
you know they're really so family
oriented for them to go through that
terrible awful trauma was horrific
to therefore have to step away from the
film um
was also horrific and not be able to
finish
uh what he was doing on top of the fact
that he had been
really uh shook i think and and
misunderstood
on uh batman vs superman and i think
that
a lot of people were worried about where
he was
whether he was going to be able to
recover from the the critical reception
of that film
and i think that it must have felt like
an enormous loss
to not get to finish that film and bring
it out
and so to see how the fans
really rallied around him and it's
just that's amazing i remember when i
saw this other singer who also had not
been able to
release a sophomore album and again it
was the fans who went in there
and had said you know we want to see we
want to hear that album you need to
release it and they did
and because those fans were were you
know vocal enough
and organized and they really were so
organized online for zach uh
in so many different ways and then there
were a lot of developments also
at warner brothers and with streaming
with the merger that then also
created also hbo max and i i guess that
like zach you know had recovered enough
from
his trauma to be able to say you know
i could do it this way but this is how i
want to get it done
and i just i
first of all it's so rare for a director
to get this opportunity
to do this it's so rare for the fans to
actually get to see
the the the thing that they've been
clamoring for
um so i am extremely
happy for zach and deb
and for the dc fans and for all of us
that we get to see
this creation i look forward to sitting
there
for four hours straight uh watching the
whole thing
you